I just listened to to our interview with
Sammy the bull Gravano I listen to it
too pretty interesting I was good after
45 yeah for me I grew up ah yes well not
at all you know for me like he was he
was like growing up in New York City
when when there was a rave a nightclub
where John Gotti and Little Italy we
used to go eat it's called Cafe Sorrento
right near Earth and you see those guys
I never saw a Gravano and I never saw
John Gotti but you saw those guys the
Goodfellas they were the good felt and
he liked what he was saying which was
John Gotti broke all the rules he
started wearing bright brown these suits
and being like a movie star they call
him the Teflon Don and Sammy the bull
was like were a secret society what the
[ __ ] is he this is my problem though
Sammy the bull whose ultimates right
he's the term for rat ultimates not
really though he but that's the thing
you watch this and it's makes it seem
like it was but he was getting Sammy the
bull was the guy who was always he was
the guy in the background he was the
killer he was he really organized he's a
killer yeah he was his aguirre terrible
human being
yeah awful oh no oh no you like I I grew
up around these guys I could tell you I
have it dude me and Stevie bless your
time like Stevie's goes here watch this
on the plane some guy well thanks TV
themes would be some pinch it watches
fantastic the case pretty closely like I
remember in New York I remember
everything that happened I think a lot
of Gotti Gotti was Gotti was the one
who's getting pissed yeah I mean Sam
Sammy Sammy was a real gangster like in
other words oh he's gone though but he
lived and died by it
Gotti John Gotti was he made his son a
capo which was you know he didn't work
his way up there was all these all these
rules he kinda broke and he became he
brought them front and center where he
became a celebrity yeah as a criminal
and these guys were like the real guys
will I be lovin [ __ ] yeah I remember
even my grandfather grew up around these
guys in Brooklyn
yeah they had my grandfather's father
helped a lot of these guys not not crime
wise but ladies guys allow these guys
were immigrants so their fathers came
over yeah any peak he had a spaghetti
sauce that factory so he'd give them
work yeah how about so when there were
strikes my grandfather's trucks were the
first ones allowed on the docks yeah so
if you didn't know it my my godfather
Redman Gemelli
he was a real tough guy
was a long short he was vice-president
Longshoremen's Union yes so so so so
there were there were rules there were
very specific rules and one of the
things that they would say is that you'd
never saw these guys you never knew you
never [ __ ] knew what they were I
remember that you never met my grandma
my mother grew up around these guys you
don't want the attention never in let
the tear and family like it was all
about family and they obviously don't
[ __ ] around with him I'm not saying they
were good guys but there was a very you
are know there was there were there were
very specific rules of the attack they
only kill each other
like the effect of family Wives remember
when he said if you were with your can I
hold my rifle right but that's why the
cartels like with it with the Mafia they
had so many legitimate businesses member
when he said if you're with your wife or
your kid I wasn't gonna kill you that's
true they never did that it was but it
was considered very very bad and in fact
when John Gotti
was turning I remember I think I got
this right
for the first time Sammy the bull and
his guys tried to kill one of got his
family members I think it was his might
have been sauna or one discussed problem
and that was I remember in the news they
were going to big yeah that's that's
what they've never done that this is
desperation time so it was it way up
here said it's super interests on
YouTube if here's Sammy talked about
though he goes you know we weren't
supposed to talk about it one supposed
to be on the news and he goes in you
definitely a snitch or each other then
John brings me in it was like hey so
they're the the DA's gonna make you have
to be the horrible guy you have to take
the fall and Jake about [ __ ] he's like
that's what you want to do you want to
give me up
yeah so he said he left that meeting was
like will [ __ ] this I'm giving him up
yeah and back in the day he said I would
have killed I would have killed Jonathan
put that point my heart was broken
because they were so close
I saw the only time I saw real mobsters
together I was it was a construction
site in New York on like 6th Avenue and
I don't know 34th Street or something
like that and I see these it was it was
so interesting every one of them
couldn't have been thicker
could have been stronger they looked
again like out of a movie real tough
guys and they were just all talking and
laughing with these big and it was so
[ __ ] obvious many were in Boston we
went to that place our friend goes be
cool here if you see girls don't be
[ __ ] harm I'm like Weissach well this
is owned by well I remember
those guys clocked you know man you
walked into these they were as tough
looking as it gets they were obviously
just connected guy yeah but they saw you
and knew who you were because you
probably fight what they watch fighting
I bet this was but right after you've
been fighting so why can't mom me yeah
they clocked you and I was just like
Jesus it was very interesting on a boy's
couple meatballs for you guys all right
hey Aurora meatballs hey guys hey you
[ __ ] hey you [ __ ] love your guy
man watch you Pete mind your P's and Q's
you get your card marked all right
you're gonna get your cut it is
interesting in it yeah the old
discipline there was a the real
discipline among the Italians and that's
why they ran the [ __ ] show have you
ever seen the the John Gotti I think it
was on history or maybe I forget a me
that's the son the son who he got
pinched right did some time here yeah he
got out and there John Gotti they have
the video of him going in prison because
he's like you know I went away my kids
were like two three four and the inside
[ __ ] I go away for six years and then I
get out I could go away for life he's
like I don't want I want to live this
life they have the video of him going
into prison telling John Gotti senior
his dad gone I don't do this anymore
dude his dad is pissed
oh yeah and he okay he was never a guy
they he didn't want to do it he was
never a guy pressure arrest the the the
Goodfellas were like this guy didn't
work his way up you just broke a bit he
also didn't want to do it either he's in
a [ __ ] black turtleneck there for
guts yeah it's not it's a very rare guy
like Sammy the bull
these guys it's very rare to be a real
gangster oppa I don't know about all of
them being sociopaths actually I think
I'll be the bull yeah well I think I
just fall into the the life and they
kill they'll kill guys from other
families and stuff like that I didn't
get sociopath from samma table I really
didn't watch one documentary no no I'd
follow this way way before he was always
like considered to be this complete
badass but again there was such a
discipline to it and he would likee I
don't know I mean looked at very
different guys different dudes check out
Carlo Gambino's underboss
I think it's Carla gander oh no who is a
guy was killed as sparks
who's the guy was killed its parks
warehouse the state same Valentine's Day
message ya know who so Sammy the bull
organized the killing of his boss Oh
Paul Castellano was the big bang yeah
look at customers underboss take a look
at this guy this guy was the real deal
Paul Castellanos Paul Castellanos
underboss yeah and they they killed him
yeah hold on no no no I just clicked it
camera this guy's name I know the old
did this today yeah I think that's
history Neal yeah look go go to images
yeah yeah look look at images of this
guy like out of a movie a couple of
pictures of him he was no Luciano was
the was the main one who made it when
he's younger than I was
he's on who made it as a business cuz
the Italian but he was a Chan I was day
he was jus like you Xian it was the one
who made it as the business and he
always wanted to you he didn't want to
sell drugs yeah he the Italians when
they came here Oh always they never want
to sell drugs they knew would end up
[ __ ] them that's right and lucky
Luciano's the guy who never want to sell
drugs
I feel like Luciano even though it's an
Italian name was Jewish am I right about
that
no that's Meyer Lansky I'm thinking of
Meyer Lansky sorry okay so did Jewish
the Jewish Mafia's work that body in
there about anybody else do it and they
invest in real businesses well though
GOG Luciano's like that he'd be the Joe
Namath of gangsters he had the [ __ ]
yeah probably judge that's that's what
they said about a lot of the gangsters
like the Jewish gangsters would like
they'd make their money but their kids
became doctors and lawyers and they
invested yeah and maybe kept going yeah
it doesn't end good for name one I mean
I'm sure they're out there with name
name either guess it's ended up well it
work ends where it ends worse and it's
better for fighters and better for
boxers that that's forgotten gangsters
are well that was the guy who said the
47 the 50 most the highest earners that
the guys who made the most money in the
mob they went to the list of 50 and this
guy was talking about the best gangsters
the ones that got away with it forever
47 are dead or in jail I mean they can
be in the deal saying it was worth I
think it's around two billion dollars
yeah you know how it is
now it's gonna happen I mean Sammy the
bull did 22 years the most depressing
part to me is when like when you watch
Goodfellas obviously it's loosely based
off gang stuff when they're going
through and he's going the restaurant
he's like a hot chicks and doing the
thing they're having fun there's slick
suit suits and yeah the the best
restaurants the hottest chicks the cars
and then when they get older and it
shows them just like oh like but that
but think about like what it's like when
you're a young man and you got all your
boys and you're not only doing what you
want this you gotta win it for a while
it's working for a while I bet it's
you're running a crew yes you're running
as a crew you're [ __ ] doing whatever
you want to hang somebody right
everybody loves you everybody loves you
get any girl you're making money you're
a gangster you're 28 or whatever the
world and then of course somebody gets
pinched and they're looking at there now
they're from now you guys are in your
40s and some of these some of these
today the FBI built a whole case and
they go to to your friends and they go
yeah you guys have been friends for 20
years you're brothers I know listen now
you're gonna go to jail ready for this
for a hundred years
yeah a hundred you'll never see your
kids really and that's what Sammy said
so yeah exactly she said they made it so
like impossible if you get caught there
you need to be so many your life's over
so guys quit [ __ ] around for once and
there are guys that took the fall there
are a lot of guys that went [ __ ] you Amy
had a great point Sammy family when it
comes to loyalty that said a lot of guys
we get put away and then they're white
they to have kids and wives and stuff
and they're the the guys from the same
mafias we've got their house [ __ ] their
wife take their money and their money
never and they're like this is this who
you're going away 30 to 40 years for it
so traditionally [ __ ] your wife that's
why the Italians you never did that
that's why traditionally if you if you
were caught [ __ ] not supporting the
family or taking the guy's wife you were
[ __ ] you you can get killed for that
yeah you can that and that's exactly why
those rules
started to crumble and one of the things
that did an article on believe it or not
he said what killed a lot of the Italian
mafia was the breakdown of family values
was the breakdown of this plan to kill
he [ __ ] said look as a southern
Italian growing up with my people like
my grandfather I can tell you that and
my mother of course I can tell you that
discipline like doing
and things there were just certain
things that you you just did and my
grandfather like as a man you were
raised as a woman you were raised with
very specific rules that you never broke
it's that old country old-school
mentality Lindo aren't there a lot of
times yeah but make no mistake the
Italians a lot of you and Rosie Italians
are very conservative people their
culture is incredibly conservative
especially the son of the South very
conservative and always work yeah my
fish it's crazy man it's crazy but drugs
man when drugs came in luckily Sean
never wanted to do a drug [ __ ]
everything and now you're looking at cuz
you know gambling running rackets you
know prostitution you do a five-year
spiritual stuff bucking heroin you're
gonna wait forever okay yeah and then
you got to kill people because now it's
meth another big things meth you know
what stopped a lot of the killing though
with the mob it's just cameras back in
the seventies eighties nineties mob guy
you you cameras everywhere cameras
ring ring on the doors everybody they
sees everything you can do [ __ ] now you
can't do those spectacular hits they
just no no see it like we're being
watched everywhere well in Chicago you
can go to where that uh it might be in
the st. Valentine's Day Mara alcohol you
can go through the where they where his
henchmen staked out to shoot underneath
his a pizza place it's one of the best
pizza place in Chicago they come in like
these [ __ ] bowls pizza was all right
more like a casserole to me but they had
good bread we can't go there and see
where they staked out to kill pretty
cool yeah pretty well yeah people are
obsessed with that mafia [ __ ] you're not
into it you mafia stuff yeah but I'm not
as into it as you guys are so you know
the Yakuza in Japan course so do you
know that most of the top guys in the
Yakuza are from Korea correct
did you know that I did know that
because well there is a little tattoo
from their neck to the toes yeah look
badass tea right oh dude pretty cool I
saw some of those guys in Shinjuku I
remember being there like a young man I
was looking at these I was like why is
that Japanese guy so [ __ ] thick just
like in a suit and I think one of the
reasons why people are in
love with mafia and biker gangs and that
in fighters because you know that
they're paying a different price than
the rest of the world to live that life
huh yeah look at those dudes again I was
just fat with titties a lot of them are
chubby yeah yeah why not yeah oh yeah
they will kill you they're badass
tattoos
how you talk watch your watch your
attitude that's a badass dude that's a
bad mother [ __ ] tattoo yeah if you're
gonna get tattoo is holy [ __ ] takes way
too long dude it don't be surprised if I
Yakuza my back out that COO so sick I
bet that takes forever to your cuz I now
while that white guy looks ridiculous
look at that damn home that could be you
Brian I want that too he's got pierced
nips that's a commitment dude it's a
commitment I don't know that's a lot in
prison yeah that's how they tell you
right by your tattoos I thought a what
gang you're affiliated with yeah a few
never got that there's no muff you know
why who's Vicki can be identified
exactly makes sense
exactly you should be done fide by your
shooter I like I love tattoos yep
they're done right I love them Wow
I want to wear that you and I should be
wearing those guys look like so is the
cops the cops made those [ __ ] guys
stand like that that's what they did
that's exactly what those cops but
earlier this show about the it's up no
those guys are standing there in front
that's a police lineup my friend that's
exactly what that is look at that dude
with the glasses
enjoy that [ __ ] with those guys [ __ ]
with that guy with it with the shades
you you [ __ ] with cocky bastard I don't
like to even tell you I don't know sir I
don't like the way you were talking
about the Cosa Nostra today the curse no
shake a little out of line and they're
out of shape of town in fact guys but
they're not tough guys they're not
beating people up with their hands
tink what like like they have guns I was
like well I'm just gonna run a mile it's
yet the other side you're not catching
me hey bro all right hey we gotta take a
minute I gotta educate him take a minute
for saying hey Brennan yeah from Aurora
explain something there you could be at
the bottom of the ocean yeah something
funny delicate nothing that I did you
could be at the bottom of the ocean the
deepest part with him lantern fish live
in a sealed [ __ ] in a sealed bank
vault top-of-the-line [ __ ] you know
lock lock yeah for what you could be in
that you could be in that okay
you could be in that and you can even
booby trap the walls so they exploded
you touch him ready hold on they would
still get to you hey we still get here
so I'm gonna and I won't breathing cute
I want pologize on your behalf oh my gum
bars I'm Goomer Goomer a bad name now
just means friend call me friend my
Goomba oh my gumballs out there I won't
apologize for my friend from Aurora
because he doesn't understand what he's
talking about doesn't understand where
he's where he's standing so please
excuse me let me apologize let me have a
talk with him I'm gonna have him take
back what he [ __ ] said yeah I mean
that now the problems Russian mafia all
right Russians are still they're a
little too ruthless but aren't they
still around not really what happened
was there a little to me in Russia they
made the problem is in the ice taste
they started killing the dog the
grandmother and everything there was
this thing that come and just kill
everybody
Russians yeah and you can't do that to
the FBI you can't do that to to the NYPD
police do they look at that dude and
they were like no no you're not guys
taking some people's souls in their body
holy [ __ ] does he look rough let's enjoy
that she got his Russian tits now he's
he's
a bad guy huh notorious Russian mob says
he just wants to go home
yeah I don't think so my man can let you
out wow that guy's scary he's embittered
yeah oh they do some dark [ __ ] man yeah
you can tell when he was younger he was
a big strong [ __ ] yeah I bet it
is the life when you're in there man I
bet as the [ __ ] life when you're
[ __ ] chucking and driving with your
buddies robbing [ __ ] yeah
getting the hottest chicks yeah just
mind your P's and Q's so you don't get
touched Rob what since I fade off a
doors little brother yeah a little I
mean giant brother yeah he's some he's
got something to do with these guys yeah
yeah yeah his back well feet are back
tattoos I guess he knows good friends
with the biggest gangster in the world
yeah yeah wisdom tours he lasted
everybody he's he's the biggest gangster
and the richest man in the world so
enjoy that he's no joke he has some dark
tattoos he's a scary [ __ ] and
trained individuals now that would be
ganks I'd be scared of yeah the big fat
guy who makes the calzones in the back
we want to be scared of anybody who's
organized and who's you know oh willing
to look at him look at him convicted
rapist gets parole oh he raped somebody
look at that [ __ ] guy or he did some
rape and he's just some a lot of stuff a
ton of family like he drinks really
heavily and well at least it was brown
that's a scary guy dude see if you go
over says who is the most gangster MMA
fighter click oh it's the forums look at
it here's the black widow tattoo which
means this one yeah there's some dark
[ __ ] when it comes to his brother yeah
these guys are you don't want to meet I
mean look at him there I just see like
they're in an alley no I don't want to
see him in my jail cell either he's
doing what he wants keeps going down god
that's his [ __ ] black widow tattoo
shows its Christ yet would did someone
from who knows their ship from Russia
broke it down and went oh
for all of it and really like so dark so
he was he was connected obviously in
yeah what was it was a KBG out there KGB
the KGB which is now a different what's
that stand for that was basically that
was their CIA oh really no CIA so the
KGB was was essentially the Russian CIA
but they they did a lot of uh a lot of
commit good theft nav but does the State
Security for the Russian mafia is
referred to about killing what were they
called
cuz Russia knows Costa Nostra I don't
know what the Russian mafia was called
but they were bad dude yeah so when they
scan you'll see because I've got a
Hampton camera we tried am I gonna
Hamsterdam some guy was it came in have
fun here and game-like names place is
the were losing drugs he said but make
sure you're not an [ __ ] there because
the Russian mafia runs all of it yeah
yeah he was there great yeah but if you
get outlined you have some press so a
lot of what happened was this the
Russian mafia had its own underworld and
stuff when the Soviet Union when the
wall came down is a word when Russia no
longer really became communist and it
became sort of a free-for-all a lot of
the people in the KGB who were trained
killers and soldiers and Special Forces
guys then Spetsnaz the KGB a lot of
those guys were like we're an
organization with no job and there's a
shitload of oil up for grabs and mineral
resources and stuff let's just go take
it yeah and so a lot of these so when
when a lot of these guys immigrated to
the United States and they were like
look America is a candy shop and there
was a guy named Friedman who wrote the
read read read something I'm red mafia
or something like that and I remember he
did an interview said they're coming and
a lot of these guys have their PhDs and
math physics these guys are very
organized they understand they
understand banking and computers and
everything else in the 90s so when they
came everybody's like they're gonna take
over everything
I remember my father I said Russian
mafia and my father started shaking
scared yeah my dad goes there you guys I
don't think so I said what I mean is so
you're gonna pit the Russian mafia
against our FBI because the last time I
checked the Russians lost the Cold War
because they couldn't organize because
there was an incentive structure point
we're taking on the United States
you think those guys are gonna fool the
FBI in their country oh there's no one
here then he was right and they they
came in they started doing they start
shaking down Russian hockey players they
they did all kinds of stuff with
businesses but then they would do really
awful things like kill everybody you
can't do that in this country you're not
allowed to do that because what would
happen is you'd have we were like wait a
minute they killed the grandmother while
she was in her rocking chair and they
killed the dog [ __ ] these guys you don't
want to piss off the our law enforcement
because they're men too and they see
that [ __ ] and they go oh well you know
what 400 okay now you guys want to take
the gloves off all right here we go yeah
so and and so a lot of those guys just
went to jail they just don't want to
June it's so fascinating man yeah yeah
and and the tattoos were you had all
these tattoos they were all so easy to
identify you know but I don't know there
was a guy there was a [ __ ] dude maybe
it was economic who was making fun of a
Russian guy tell his story in New York
City comic was making fun of a Russian
guy and he was like kind of a not
affected and he was with a girl and he
was and the guy was in the thing of this
one you could smoke and he's going like
this and he wasn't laughing and you know
just listening to him and that comic
that night disappeared was in a dumpster
just found a dumpster they killed a [ __ ]
in a dumpster I'll tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]